Okay. Thank you everyone for joining me. This
is a new podcast that we're launching called
the Cloud Native Compass, which focuses on containers,
Kubernetes, WebAssembly, and everything in between.
And today's episode, we are talking about WebAssembly
and server side WebAssembly.
I have three wonderful guests who will each
introduce themselves now, and we'll start with you,
Kevin.
So I'm Kevin Hoffman, CTO of Cosmic.
Created the WasmCloud open source project,
wrote a book called programming web assembly with
Rust,
and
just in general have been using and experimenting
with web assembly since,
well, since before the standards were fully baked.
Thank you very much. Connor.
Hello.
I'm Connor Hicks. I'm the founder CEO of
Suborbital.
We focus on using server side WebAssembly for
the purposes of building
extensibility
into SaaS applications.
We build effectively
a plug in system for
SaaS,
cloud based apps. And
I was experimenting with WebAssembly for probably two
or three years before that, so I've
seen a little bit, but don't think I've
been around quite as long as Kevin.
Hi, everyone. My name is Kate Goldenring.
I'm a senior software engineer at Fermion where
we're excited about serverless WebAssembly applications.
And previously, I came from a Kubernetes background.
So I'm still a co chair of the
IoT Edge working group and the CNCF. So
still enjoy the Kubernetes space
and currently have moved into this new WebAssembly
world, excited about the serverless side of it.
Alright. Thank you.
So as part of your introduction, as you've
all obviously shared a little bit about how
you got into WebAssembly, but I'm hoping we
can dive into that a little bit more
and just kinda understand not just
why you're here, but, like, what your path
was to get to WebAssembly. What did you
find interesting? What feature like, what really got
you on that road to join in this
in the WebAssembly landscape?
So there's no right order here. If anyone
wants to tackle that question first, please feel
free to blink twice, put up your hand,
anything you wish.
So
a while ago, and this was, you know,
when we were all riding to the office
on the backs of dinosaurs,
I was trying to solve a
enterprise problem
where I had a number of teams that
were all trying to contribute
business logic to
a shared portal.
And so one of the problems I was
trying to fix was
how do I make it so that these
teams can all work in the environments that
they're comfortable in
and still and the languages that they're comfortable
with and still be able to contribute to
this,
you know, shared target platform.
And so
one of the many thousands of rabbit holes
I went down
took me to
AsmJS.
And then
I also did some experimenting with
this thing called CloudAVI,
which to me feels like a sort of
a spiritual
ancestor to Wazzy.
And
from there, the rabbit hole just grew bigger
and bigger until
I found
my way to web assembly and,
you know, wrote my first Hello World in
in c. And then,
you know, once I figured out how to
do it in Rust, it was pretty much
all downhill from there.
And the
the technology that ended up helping these various
teams do what they needed to do
is what ultimately ended up as part of
the open source Wasm cloud project. Okay.
For me, it was
a
COVID,
you know, playing on my own open source
projects type thing where I got frustrated
with
how containers were behaving in a particular project
that I've been playing with on the weekends
while we were in lockdown.
And
I had kinda filled around with WebAssembly
before that, but I
decided to try to pull it into this
project I was working on to try to
get faster
startup times for
basically a job processing
framework that I was building.
And
I pulled it in. It was
a very rudimentary Rust
implementation
with a couple of very basic bindings to
be able to, you know, just read system
stuff. This was while Wazy was still a
little bit,
you know, in its early days.
And
the thing that really got me hooked was
that that performance that I was able to
pull out of the, the job scheduling
system that I was building compared to the
previous implementation of it that was based on
containers.
And so, you know, that that one weekend
of hacking was enough to convince me that
there is some real utility for WebAssembly,
and then that was about three years ago.
So now I've been working on it full
time since then.
Yeah. I mentioned in
my intro that I kind of came from
the Kubernetes ecosystem. That's exactly what brought me
into the WebAssembly space,
which is a bit unusual. But I was
maintaining
and still am a project called Aukri, which
is a CNCF sandbox project. And while I
was at Microsoft and we were trying to
we were wondering what would it look like
to port this application to being a WebAssembly
application.
And we had a sister team, which is
the Dais Labs team, of which many of
those people now came and founded Fermion that
was working on a project called Crestlet,
which was basically a a first attempt at
what does it look like to run WebAssembly
instead of containers on Kubernetes.
And so I jumped into that effort and
implemented,
the device plug in manager in that Kubernetes
kubelet,
written in Rust, which is why it's called
Crestlet,
and kind of saw some of the issues
we were having around
using a new kubelet implementation as the way
of running WebAssembly on Kubernetes and how just
the load of what we needed to do
kept getting bigger and bigger because it was
a full kubelet. And
at that point, many people had switched to
moving on to Fermion, and I kinda got
hooked on WebAssembly seeing all the benefits on
the server side that originally
were those benefits that were made for the
browser. So that made me also join
on with Fermion and keep going in the
WebAssembly space.
Thank you. So, you know, all three of
you mentioned server side,
Wazi,
for people that aren't that familiar with what
the Wazi
as a as a spec yeah. Specification. Right?
What that is? Maybe we can give them
a bit more context on why that's important
for today's discussion.
So I guess I'll start with the hard
part, which is that Wazi is
influx
and it's one of those things that
means something different to different people even though,
you know, it's it's an official standard. Right?
So when when you look at
WASI, some people
and again, the documentation
in different places treats it this way is
they feel like they treat WASI as though
it's
like a POSIX replacement but for web assembly.
And
it may have originated
that way and with that goal in mind,
but
the way things are going today, it seems
more like the WASI is
more along the lines of
the
the implementation technology that's enabling things like the
component model.
And so
I guess the the short version is that
WASI
was originally created as a way to give
WebAssembly modules access to
external services, but those external services were
low level, like being able to read from
a file descriptor or being able to write
to standard out and things like that.
And
that
seems to be evolving towards the component model
where
now
the idea is that the the external services
are
high level abstractions like web client, web server,
key value store, things like that. Oh, I
was just gonna add just because I don't
know if we've said it yet. WASI stands
for the web assembly systems interface. So it's
what Kevin's mentioning. It's those interfaces that are
allowing a guest or a web assembly module
or soon to be component to talk to
a host and use those resources from the
host. And it's essentially just a wit or
that type of file where you're defining all
these functions that give access to your guest
code, those resources on the host.
And as Kevin mentioned, it's been evolving to
from providing just the bare minimum of what
you may need to run an application directly
on the server into more of this idea
of what is what does a cloud look
like that is made up of web assembly
functions. And so we're getting those key value
services and other kinds of services that you
would expect from the cloud, and all that's
being defined by these WIT interfaces
that give access to host resources or other
resources that the host can
point out control to.
Yeah. Another way I like to look at
it is
think of an interface in a programming language,
being able to define an abstract set of
methods or
behaviors for an object and then having multiple
implementations of that within that language.
You can think of Wazee and the associated
component model as a generalized version of that
where you can define a set of interfaces.
Some of them will be
common and and set by a standards body
as, you know, the things that you need
every day, like accessing randomness and the clocks
and stuff like that. But some of them
will be user generated, and at the end
of the day, you result in
a shape, a an external,
set of inputs and outputs that any module
written in theoretically any language could conform to.
And if you load a module that conforms
to that interface, it will theoretically satisfy the
requirements of your program.
And that's, I think, where we wanna get
to,
and it's just a matter of working through
that very complicated problem in the standards body,
and that's what's happening right now.
Okay. So what I'm gonna try and do
is repeat all of that back in a
summary fashion and hopefully not get too much
of it wrong, but feel free just to
let me know. I I'm I'll make some
assumptions as I go. But, you know, I
think what I heard from Kevin is if
we could take a Wazee something like POSIX,
but not directly like POSIX, then it allows
us to be able to speak to the
host fail system, to the networking stack, and
so forth.
It feels like it was said that the
component model was an evolution of this or
an implementation of this. I'm not sure which,
but maybe someone can clarify that. But what
that means is both.
Yeah. Yeah. We'll go with both or it
depends. I like the answer to
depends what we use to squint your eyes.
But,
you know, we have the component model there
and we the reason that we need this,
right, even if we go back a little
bit more is that WebAssembly as a runtime
is a really strict sandbox. Right? Is it
safe to assume that it has no concept
of a file system. Right? Because it runs
in the browser. It has no concept of
I don't know. I mean, it has networking.
Right? But does it understand
layer seven? Is it just l four? Does
it have none of that? I'm not even
entirely sure myself. But these sorts of primitives
that don't exist in the sandbox and the
component model
enriches that with some of these common interfaces
like Kate and Connor were saying. I think
Kate, your example was k v storage.
If we provide an interface, the k v
get and k v set It depends. Yeah.
Does that mean the component model can drop
in a Redis component, a MySQL component,
a, you know, a simple file component that
does, you know, files as the best TV.
And then as a consumer within
your WebAssembly program,
you don't care.
Is that is that right? Yeah. I think
the main so there were two things that
I I
wanted to point out. So one is,
again, depending on what you're using it as
your your definition of WebAssembly.
WebAssembly on its own, so the the standard,
the one dot o freestanding
web assembly has no concept of networking. So
there's no networking. There's no file system access.
There's no IO at all. There's just the
ability to
take in numbers and give back numbers.
And
that's
essentially a direct
result of the sandbox that you're working in.
The only thing that WebAssembly on its own
without the assistance of a host can do
is just pure functional compute
and
access a shared
sandbox piece of memory.
And that's all it can do. So the
first thing that people run into when they
do that is
they need
they need access to more than just pure
compute.
And so how do you do that? The
the first thing that enabled people to do
that was Wazee
And they were able to then access,
you know, sandboxed file systems.
And
what we're talking about as the evolution
of that is what you were saying where
the next step is
to grant abilities
or to grant these
interfaces to the guest modules to the components.
So moving moving forward from
Wazee's low level
capabilities
to the next level up. So, you know,
high level cloud services. And just to follow-up
on your question, David, I think you mentioned
there that, yeah, you can have your guest
then point to multiple
use different hosts over this interface. So in
the key value scenario,
you're saying you can do a series of
gets and sets.
The interesting part about this isn't one, like
you said, that as
a developer, I don't need to care about
what the host implementation is or whether I
use Redis or DynamoDB,
for example. But another part of it is
that I could change my mind.
So I can have the same web assembly
module,
and keep that constant. And then maybe later,
I want to switch to Redis.
Then I don't need to rewrite that that
application. I just need to change the host
side of it.
And then one other point I wanted to
make is I think Wazee and the component
model, I personally see them as
very related because the specification is moving towards
the component model. But I think it's easy
to think of them as separate in the
sense of I think of the component model
as a new way of envisioning applications
and the way that we see applications and
making them composable
and,
making
essentially dependencies.
You can click them in place and swap
them out more easily.
But I think of Wazee as this evolution
that enabled us to run WebAssembly
outside of the browser
that has now decided that a really good
way we wanna do this even more so
is with this new way of making applications
with the component model.
Yeah. I think
what's
what's important that Kate was mentioning that I
think
it's it's subtle and a lot of people
don't really
see the impact that it's going to have
right away, but the idea that you can
change your mind
at run time
between
implementations of these contracts
is
way more enabling than
some of the technologies that have come before
it. So
in addition to me being able to change
my mind about which implementation
of a key value store I'm I'm dealing
with,
I can change that
at run time.
I mean, depending on the host, obviously, but
I can change that without having to rebuild
my code. My code is now
no longer tightly coupled to the shape and
scale of my deployment.
Yeah. And and a kind of adjacent benefit
that you would get that I don't think
we've really seen with any other technologies is
the ability to not only change out implementations
at runtime,
which will be extremely awesome in its own
right, but then also the ability to move
code
to different layers
of the,
excuse me, the network stack, I guess, one
way to look at it. Like, you can
move code from executing in a central AWS
region out to, like, an edge worker style
region
and not have to change it at all
because maybe in your central cloud, you use
DynamoDB for KV, but then on the edge,
use the Cloudflare Workers cache or something like
that. And you would be able to either
manual or maybe even one day automatically depending
on load or whatever,
you could move the execution of that code
around, and it could just figure out how
to make your business logic work with the
dependencies that it needs.
Okay. Thank you for that. So there's a
few different interesting things here. Right? It's like
we've mentioned containers a couple of times now.
And, like, this containers would be, like, what
we consider almost the standard developer experience for
a lot of what we're talking about right
now is the ability to use different backing
services. Right?
But how is WebAssembly changing that? Now we've
got a component model and this is runtime
thing that we can swap out and the
code doesn't change a lot. That's all very
nice. But like,
how does WebAssembly
really continue to improve that developer experience for
developers? Like, why are we seeing what started
off as this browser based technology for doing
computation now being used for functions and service
within game engines even on mobile phones and,
you know, desktop extensibility is another one. Like,
Versus Code is probably gonna have a plug
in system that's mostly web assembly based at
some point.
Why are so many people being drawn to
this versus the status quo of like containers?
Yeah. I think the
there's two or three main points depending on
who you are and what you care about.
One of them is the fact that web
assembly modules are often far more lightweight than
your average container. That's not always 100% true,
but on the average case, that is that
is true. And so, therefore, storing them,
downloading them,
starting the execution of them is often much
faster.
The second is the security posture. A lot
of people
see you know, since WebAssembly was an evolution
of something that came out of a web
browser and web browsers run untrusted code all
day long safely on your laptop,
since WebAssembly was born from that, it could
bring some real security improvements to cloud,
execution as well,
both in terms of, like, you know, third
party dependency vulnerabilities
and
just malicious
stuff that makes it into your your sort
of source code, but also
intentionally running untrusted code.
And then the third is just a common
target for multiple programming languages.
Containers
somewhat satisfy that,
but the ability to, as we just talked
about in the last few minutes, like, have
a common set of interfaces,
capabilities, APIs available to you, and then being
able to have all the different programming languages
that you care about target that exact same
environment
and
not have the overhead of a Linux like
environment
to go along with it has a a
couple of really great benefits. Yeah. There's a
there's a couple of things that I think
people take for granted.
So
one is that the the idea that containers
are portable is
untrue.
Right? Containers aren't actually portable. There are,
you know, there's a whole
cottage industry of tools to help
compensate
for the lack of portability around containers.
And
the there's a a saying
I'm not sure where the quote came from
but
you own what you deploy.
So your unit of deployment is
something is everything that you own.
And so the larger the thing that you
deploy, the larger your ownership burden is. Right?
So we started off
deploying in virtual machines an entire operating system
plus the application that we needed to deploy.
And so we own basically everything from top
to bottom. Then with containers,
we own
a
slice of an operating system
and our application and all the application dependencies.
But with
WebAssembly,
all we own theoretically
is our business logic. We don't own the
external dependencies anymore because we're no longer shipping
them with our WebAssembly modules.
Right? Assuming that the future with this component
model
turns out the way we all want it
to,
I don't own
the implementation
of the key value store
that I that for my
WebAssembly component that I'm shipping.
I can ship that somewhere and then the
environment is the thing that owns
that database.
So I may still care about it and
because I may, you know, have multiple hats,
I may still be the one who's, you
know, dealing with the
the implementation and the installation and configuration of
all that stuff. But
in terms of
the developer working on
just that module,
they don't have to worry about owning that
full full stack anymore. All they own is
their use of the abstraction.
Okay. So thank you for saying that containers
are not portable.
As a developer working on an m one
Mac, I guarantee you containers are not build
once run everywhere.
And I think the tooling there is
is really painful right now. That's one of
the draws for me personally with web assembly.
It's that you do just you you build
it once you get the web assembly
binary artifact, whatever that is, and it it
does run everywhere, which is really cool. But
I'm gonna take that that question that I
asked. I'm gonna flip it around a little
bit and see
if people are listening
and they like the idea of web assembly.
They like the idea of
working in random languages. We've already said rust
three times now, so let's get that up
to at least 12 before the end of
the episode. But they wanna explore those languages.
They wanna compel to us a common ubiquitous
target that does run anywhere.
What kind of applications
does the current state of the component model
and was it really excel with? Like and
I'm assuming rewrite in Postgres is not the
answer there. So what
can we do today?
Yeah. I think you pointed out where well,
they're of saying a long running daemon style
application like a database is not what you
probably wanna target for Wazee WebAssembly at the
moment.
What seems to be a really good use
case for WebAssembly right now is serverless. If
you think about
the
previous unit for serverless or
maybe micro VMs is a common one for
AWS Lambda, Firecracker micro VMs, those take about
a hundred and twenty five milliseconds for
cold starts, while WebAssembly is sub millisecond.
And so you can really see event driven
applications that need to run from a cold
start,
execute, and go down in millisecond or sub
millisecond time. WebAssembly is a really good use
case for that. Yeah. I'm
I wanna I I don't remember who brought
it up, but the
ability to change your mind also extends to
this type of thing. So
Kate's point is excellent in that, you know,
WebAssembly is great at serverless,
but I think what's even more important
is that you're not locked into serverless
with WebAssembly.
So,
you know, you can run a WebAssembly component
as a
stateless
wake on demand function
or you could leave it running
and
have it, you know, have 500 instances of
your WebAssembly module distributed across,
you know, hundreds of different servers.
And
your decision at that point is just a
choice of which runtime or which host you
wanna deploy your your component into.
And
your
your choice of using serverless or a micro
service
or some other hybrid
is no longer a
design once and live with the consequences forever
decision,
you can actually change your mind. You can
go from
running it serverless in a test environment on
your laptop to running it distributed across
multiple clouds in production without having to rebuild
your modules.
Okay. I'm gonna ask the hard question now.
And it's like, you know, the the what's
missing, like, the I I I don't even
know how to phrase it in a way
that's gonna even help you answer it. But
let's assume we have a world ten years
from now where all applications are written as
WebAssembly.
What are we doing to push into these
things where we quite missed the mark right
now? Like, how do we write long run
and doing processes for purpose? Like, how do
we have databases that are purely written in
WebAssembly?
Is it just a maturity thing? Is there
a tooling thing? Is it the component model?
We need a v two. Like, what what's
the trajectory there? What's the path forward to
being fully Wasm? We we need a v
one before we need a v two.
Yeah. There's a couple of things that come
to mind.
One is,
you know, debugging and observability.
This is something where we've seen a bunch
of prototypes. We've seen a bunch of projects
working towards being able to easily debug and
observe WebAssembly execution.
But
just like the component model, they're in flux.
People are still trying to agree upon the
best way to do it, and the tools
aren't fully baked yet.
The component model itself, like I said, we're
not even at v one yet.
So getting to something that we all agree
on, and we can say, okay. This is
going to be stable for the foreseeable future.
And, you know, future updates will require breaking
or migration or whatever. Like, that is going
to be an an important inflection point for
the whole industry.
And then I think just having the different
language tool chains catch up to that. Once
we have that v one of the component
model, we then have more work to do.
Right? Having just the spec isn't enough. Rust
will obviously get there quickly,
but then
all the other languages
need to integrate the component model tooling,
be compliant with the spec.
And there's an additional layer of complexity for
the interpreted languages like JavaScript and Python
to
for for all of those things, the component
model and debugging and and the tooling. So
there's just a couple of steps I think
we need. All of those things,
we're we're seeing progress on them.
And if we
kind of get to this point of coalescing
on the standards and the tooling and the
tool chains,
then we should
be able to see that future pretty clearly.
I think
at a really high level,
so Connor mentioned a bunch of different types
of tooling, but in general, the tooling is
just not there yet. There are some languages
with better tooling than others, so I think
we would all agree that Rust probably has
the best tooling ecosystem right now.
But
so the the tooling obviously needs to evolve,
but I think even at a higher level
is WebAssembly
is not yet a boring technology.
So
part of the giant hype cycle around WebAssembly
is that everybody is trying to
get into the space
and
the the difference between now and
the ideal future is
WebAssembly becomes boring.
It no longer is an end goal and
is just a checkbox that you tick when
building something. You write your code. It comes
out as a component.
All the tooling knows how to deal with
components.
You have tooling that stitch components together, and
it's all just
part of the day to day routine.
When when WebAssembly is
as easy to produce as an ELF binary,
then that's when
the you know, that's part of the tipping
point when
things go from
the
the dangerous part of the adoption curve to
everybody's using it even if they don't know
about it. Yeah. Just if I think Kevin's
exactly correct in that. If we get to
a point where WebAssembly
fades in the background in the same way
that a lot of developers don't even know
that they are interacting with POSIX or whatever.
Like, it should proceed
to a similar level of
so boring and so reliable that it just
is a standard,
then
we will have succeeded.
And just to add on to the comment
about it being a standard, it is a
standard, and it's community driven. So there is
a pace at which things move,
and
that does require that
we get certain interfaces in place. Recently,
we got threads.
We got socket accept. But without those things,
you can't even imagine a long living Daemon
application. So you can see we're moving forward,
but there are other proposals that still need
to happen.
And the other thing that we need is
a registry for all of these different components.
So if you Warg is what it's called.
But if you can imagine one place where
you can centralized use other people's components
and make a composable application. So a developer
experience that's easier around that too. So I
don't need to know how to make every
component,
or even understand the low level WebAssembly tooling.
Yeah. I think the day
will come when
we'll have a
nearly universal package registry.
Like Kate's point about work and having
this, this library of components you could pull
from. Like, that is one of the big
dreams, I think, of WebAssembly is that I
could be writing a Python program.
I need a library to do some hashing
algorithm that I don't know how to implement
in Python.
I could pull down a package
that implements that algorithm, and I might not
even have any idea what programming language that
algorithm was written in. It could be c.
It could be rust. And I won't know
or care
what language that came from because the tooling
will just understand that, hey. This is a
component.
I can understand how to load and run
a component or compile it into my larger
program or whatever,
and we just continue on. Yeah. I think
that's a subtle and
often overlooked point is that when we when
we switch to the component model,
the the size of the the LEGO bricks
that we're using to compose our applications is
much smaller.
And so
when we talk about how, you know,
it's WebAssembly is language agnostic
or you can use any language,
a lot of people immediately think, well, I
can that just means I can choose one
language to build my application in
and another team can choose another language.
And while that's true, I think some of
the real
underrated power comes from
what Connor was mentioning, which is if I
have
if I am am trying to build an
application and let's say I need to do
some,
you know, heavy duty cryptography type stuff and
there's a different language where
that's easy to do in its WebAssembly targeting
form.
And so I could
write my business logic in Go,
build a WebAssembly
component out of that and utilize
another component that does the quote unquote hard
stuff for me
and the component that I I've
that I link with at compile time or
run time,
that could do that stuff for me and
I don't care what language it's written in.
All I care is that it satisfies the
contract. So that
the idea that I have these contracts
and interfaces that are being satisfied
at a high level, that means that I
can interchange things like my database or my
web server and things like that. But at
a low level, it means that I can
actually build
applications
out of
units of compute that are smaller than what
we think of today as traditional libraries.
And that's super powerful, I think. Yeah. I
think that's one of the often understated powers
of WebAssembly. And I hadn't really thought about
it directly like this.
And, you know, there is no WebAssembly package
package thing yet. But using NPM as an
example, if I'm working on a an application
and I just do NPM install three different
packages that are running three different languages, but
I'll get billed to WebAssembly and I'm able
to consume them
in a really strong developer experience fashion.
That's really powerful to a lot of people,
you know, especially if you're have a data
science team that wanna work in Python. You've
got your web dev team that wanna work
in Ruby. You've got, you know, your infrastructure
team here all go and rust and then
it doesn't matter at this point in time
anymore. We're just consuming each other's interfaces, abstractions,
and components, which very,
I like I like that feature. That's the
future I'm here for. I want that one.
So
Alright.
Well, I know two of you, Kevin and
Kate, you were both at KubeCon. I'm not
sure if you were there, Connor. Right? No.
Okay. But I'm assuming
that's not the only conference on the circuit.
You've all been to many conferences over the
last twelve or twenty four months or whatever.
Like, I'm I'm curious just when you speak
to people and you say WebAssembly,
is there an instant acknowledgement? We had a
phase where people are like, oh, WebAssembly. Or
is it like a, oh, what's that? Tell
me more. Like, what's that like these days?
I think the way that I have seen
that evolve is just standing in front of
our Fermion booth at KubeCons.
And
just a year ago at, KubeCon North America,
so I guess less than a year ago,
the first initial question of, hey. Do you
wanna learn about WebAssembly?
There was immediate what?
And now it's evolving to
people already know what that is a lot
of times, and that's been really interesting to
see in just eight months or so how
the just that
experience of people walking by, they already know
that. And oftentimes, they want to hear more
and learn more. And we had several WebAssembly
workshops at KubeCon. We had one about spin
on AKS, and then
WASM Edge had another one. And there were,
like, 350
people at our session for this workshop hands
on with WebAssembly.
And then there seemed to be around, like,
200 or so at the Wasm Edge 1.
So people not only are hearing about it
and interested in it, but also wanting to
get hands on with it. And it seemed
like that's happened fairly quickly.
Yeah. The session that I gave at KubeCon,
like you said, I've I've presented at a
couple of conferences and have been for a
while now.
And I can distinctly remember, you know, giving
presentations when there were, like, three people in
the room
a total,
and those three people didn't know what WebAssembly
was.
And then there was a a next step
where there were more
interested people in the room, but none of
them had really experimented with WebAssembly yet. And
at this most recent cube con, the room
was completely full which is a a totally
new experience for WebAssembly
for the WebAssembly community.
And
in addition to be there being people that
were just interested in the technology, there were
actually people who raised their hand for
people who'd used WebAssembly in anger and had
been building real things and deploying real things
with it, not using a browser, which,
you know, I'm
actively trying to make that in the future
and that completely surprised me. I just had
no idea that
it was catching on that quickly. And,
from the WASM clock booth and Cosmonic booth
and just sort of walking around and talking
to people,
people generally seem to know not only what
web assembly is
but
it's no longer a really really hard sell
trying to tell people that WebAssembly has a
place outside the browser.
I think we're we're starting to get to
the point where the early adopters
and the innovation curve now includes people that
don't just assume that WebAssembly is a browser
only technology. And I think that's a that's
a huge milestone for the community.
Yeah. I think it's it speaks a lot
that a first edition of a new WebAssembly
conference, WASM.io, that happened a couple weeks ago
was able to draw such a great crowd.
And this was something that was not attached
to a larger conference like the WASM days
at KubeCon.
Those ones have been steadily getting bigger. Like
Kevin said, we've had full rooms and whatnot.
But even a brand new conference was able
to pull in enough people to to, be
extremely successful and and also, you know, the
quality of speakers does is, I think, a
given because everybody in this community is very
friendly and talented. But,
yeah, it's been a steady increase,
and I think the the rate of change
is is increasing as well as people see
things getting a bit more mature. They see
examples of real word real world usage,
and they start to
realize
where the use cases are,
you know, filtering out to. It's definitely becoming,
easier to
talk about, easier to
convince people of its utility, and you're finding
a larger percentage of people just inherently
already knowing it, which is great. And on
the note of Wazamayo
and great speakers, I just wanted to shout
out PJ Laskowitz,
talk on
basically all these different production scenarios.
He's with the Omnify Foundation,
and I was so excited by the end
of his talk. He was mentioning how it's
being used in production in medical devices, automotive,
the edge. I it was just stuff that
I had no clue was already happening in
production.
So if you wanna get excited about it
as well, that's definitely a really,
interesting talk to watch. Nice.
So
Kevin said something that kinda made me smile
a little bit. And he said that WebAssembly
isn't just a thing that we run-in a
browser.
From my perspective, and I'm not a front
end dev. Right? So I've got a lot
of bias here. But the Wazi server side
WebAssembly stuff is probably being used much more
than WebAssembly in the browser. And I don't
know if that's just because I'm not in
the front end world,
but I have tried to write WebAssembly to
run an browser from my website. And I
just didn't think the tooling was as mature
or good as what we have on server
side WebAssembly.
But I again, just from my perspective, I
think server side WebAssembly is moving faster and
better
than in browser WebAssembly.
Yeah. I think I think people got to
production
with browser
based WebAssembly
first, like Figma, for example, and and Adobe
and others.
But I have just a is purely just
observational on my part. Like, there are more
startups and companies
that have been formed around the server side
of things, whereas the web browser side of
things has been more just
purely community and and, like, open source and
not driven by companies and startups. So I
think that could be contributing to why it
seems like the Wazee and server side part
of it has been
progressing faster or maybe there's just more noise
about it. That's that could be at least
from my side, that's what I've been observing.
I think it depends on the metric you're
using to
to measure size. So,
you know,
WebAssembly in the browser has probably reached more
people
because it's in the browser. It's probably reached
more people than
you know, people don't know that they're using
it. So, you know, Conor brought up Figma.
There's
it's
making its way into all kinds of web
based applications and it's just sort of a
an understood thing now. Adobe has applications
on on the web that use the that
use WebAssembly.
So
sheer number of people who,
you know, have have hit a web page
that's using WebAssembly is
probably pretty high.
But to Connor's point, I think the
the
real
developer ecosystem
growth
right now is definitely happening on the server
side.
Yeah. I'm sure there's probably a Cloudflare report
because they do these reports every year that
talks about traffic and distribution and technologies being
used. I'm sure web assemblies in there somewhere
is a number, and we just have to
find it. But I imagine those numbers are
pretty huge.
But we are approaching the end of our
session, and I I wanna just kinda throw
out and talk about Docker's recent announcement and
what that means for web to back end
developers and WebAssembly and hybrid architectures.
But, you know, Docker and container d, a
couple of weeks ago, announced that
we can now use container d to distribute
and pull
OCI images,
which contain
Wasm binaries.
These can be run side by side with
containers using something like Docker Compose and the
container these shims even allow us to we've
run Wasi to run these workloads in Kubernetes.
So we're seeing
and what I'm excited about personally has been
able to do a Docker Compose up and
have, like, a Postgres or a Redis or
whatever.
My WebAssembly application running
and all speaking to each other with no
effort and being able to ship that to
Kubernetes.
And I'm curious what your thoughts are. Do
we think that hybrid architectures with containers and
WebAssembly side by side is gonna be the
next big thing over the next, what, five
years, let's call it?
I don't know if it's the next big
thing
as much it is a a necessary step
in bridge building.
So,
you know, right now, like, we said,
we all pretty much agree that the ideal
future is
one where you just build a WebAssembly component
and then you choose where to deploy it
based on the features of the host runtime
you're deploying it to. It's no longer a
technical concern. It's more, you know,
just shopping for features.
And
to get there, we need to bridge between
people's legacy code today and
people writing greenfield WebAssembly components.
And so one of those steps is to
make it so that people can run
certain types of WebAssembly workloads in Docker and,
you know, with run Wazy and things like
that.
I think it's a little misleading because there's
only a certain type of WebAssembly
modules that you can run-in these things.
You know, if you're if you're building a
WebAssembly module that uses a very specific subset
of WASI, then
it sort of just works.
But if you need access to other types
of runtime services,
you know, maybe ones that
you need access to through the component model
or through proprietary interfaces.
You can't get those in
the Docker
environment.
So there's still a lot of work to
do, but
it's a it's a foot in the door
and a step in the right direction to
get
adoption going. So
we start out with hybrid architectures and then,
you know, eventually, we move to the the
the pure electric model, right, where now
we're not using we're not tethered to any
of the legacy stuff. Our our greenfield stuff
works just fine.
I'm gonna do some more hyperbole here. You
start your sentence with, yes, this is the
next big thing. If you're not writing WebAssembly
next to your containers, you're gonna lose your
job and you're not gonna be a developer
anymore. That's what we need to tell people.
Right?
But that was your answer was too balanced.
I'll I'll add it to the up. It's
fine. Don't worry about it.
Any thoughts, Kate or Connor?
I would just say as a short answer,
I do think
containers and WebAssembly will live next to each
other.
And that will probably happen for a long,
long time,
if not forever.
Because
people might not wanna move their legacy code
to WebAssembly. And, also, some things do are
suited well for containers,
like we said, those databases that maybe your
WebAssembly
module still communicates with. Whether Kubernetes
or Docker is the way you want to
orchestrate or run WebAssembly,
right now, it is a great stepping stone.
Like Kevin mentioned, it might not be fully
featured, and maybe it will become fully featured,
or maybe there will be something else that
will better suit running and orchestrating WebAssembly.
Yeah. I think
Docker is
a very common
tool for
developers to have in their toolkit these days.
They probably already have Docker desktop installed.
And
so Docker is essentially giving the WebAssembly community
a bit of a a boost here where
if a developer
comes across WebAssembly, they're interested in trying it
out. Docker just lowered the bar in in
terms of complexity to get started and try
it out, which is undeniably
a very important thing.
Whether or not
the, you know, Docker Compose
method of combining containers and WebAssembly will be
the thing that is, you know, shipped to
production environments or whether it's even the paradigm
that we use going forward, I don't know.
And whether Kubernetes is involved or not, I
don't know. There's obviously you can find tons
of think pieces about that around the Internet,
and I won't go into it. But I
think,
Docker is just such a well understood tool
for a lot of people at this point,
and it's going to be
as both,
Kate and Kevin said, it's going to be
a stepping stone. It's gonna be a bridge.
It's going to be a step towards
getting us to that next evolution where
WebAssembly is just a fact of everyday life.
We'll
sometimes use it, sometimes not. Maybe we won't
even know,
and this is a good step. Awesome. Well,
thank you all so much. It's been an
honor speaking with you all. I'm now gonna
allow you all just to have some shameless
plugs.
Feel free to share links, Twitter handles, websites,
anything that you want of the audience, and
I'll make sure that they are all in
the show notes too. So we will work
in reverse.
We'll go with you, Kate, first, if you
wanna start and
take it away. Okay. Well,
I guess you can find me on Kate
Golden Ring at Twitter, but on Twitter. But
for anything, if you're curious about Fermion and
on how it does serverless web assembly,
that's simply fermion.com.
And you can get started deploying serverless applications
to Fermion cloud, and we say sixty six
seconds or less. So we're really about that.
Web assembly, easy to get started,
developer experience.
And that's,
we mentioned key value a lot. And in
part, we just launched key value support in
the cloud. So if you're excited to see
what that looks like right now, you can
go ahead and try that out. Yeah. You
can find me on
pretty much anything at cohix, c o h
I x, the hacky derm server on Mastodon,
Twitter,
blue sky, but I haven't logged into that
more than one time so far.
As for suborbital, like I said at the
beginning, we help you integrate a plug in
system into your SaaS application,
uses our
globally distributed edge network to execute
these untrusted plug ins, and the
developers can write plug ins using a completely
web browser based code editor.
No local installs needed,
and
you can check all of that out at
suborbital.dev.
So
Cosmonic is
that's my product, and we provide a
managed hosting environment for
WebAssembly applications.
And
so you can
deploy
components. You can deploy modules.
We have key value store up and running.
We have
what you deploy can have public web endpoints.
And so we talked earlier about the need
to orchestrate applications
and
you can orchestrate a WebAssembly
a distributed WebAssembly
application in Cosmonic with no need for Docker.
And, you know, the website
is just cosmonic.com,
and there's a there's a launch button in
there for our free trial.